[Musique]
bonjour Francis Perrin
bonjour bonjour
et merci d'être avec nous alors on va on
va parler avec vous de Molière qui a été
qui est la grande affaire de votre vie
évidemment et puis de de L'École des
femmes puisque vous serez aux Mureaux
vous êtes au bureau le 25 novembre
c'est un spectacle que vous avez mis en
scène et que vous interprétez vous
interprétez le rôle d'Arnolphe mais il y
a aussi gersante Perrin qui est votre
épouse qui est interprète Georgette ça
servante il y a aussi Claris Perrin
votre fille qui interprète Agnès Agnès
vous savez le petit chat est mort tout
le monde se souvient de cette réplique
évidemment culte et puis Louis Perrin
votre fils qui joue au race on va on va
parler après de lui qui est donc
laboureux d'Agnès au grand Damme
d'ailleurs d'Arnolphe je résume en deux
mots la pièce à Arnold est un homme dans
certains nages qui voudrait bien se
marier mais il a une peur bleue d'être
trompé en gros et donc il se dit il y a
une une idée c'est de c'est d'élever il
a une pupille qui est qui s'appelle la
dièse qui est qui est là et il dit je
vais l'épouser et pour que pour que je
parle d'enduit au fond je vais la faire
élever dans la plus grande
ignorance
absolument c'est ça c'est ça et depuis
l'âge de 4 ans il a il l'a mise dans un
couvent il a fait sortir là
elle a 17 ans il dit ben je vais
l'épouser ce qui est absolument aberrant
même pour cette époque là enfin je veux
dire c'était quelque chose et c'est ce
que Molière dénonce d'ailleurs
extraordinairement
et d'ailleurs pardon mais c'est vrai que
on l'a dit et c'est tout à fait c'est
une des premières pièces féministe et
alors vous dites c'est vrai même pour
l'époque mon frère il faut quand même se
rappeler au fait les 400 ans de la
naissance de Molière c'est pas rien
quand même voilà et on s'aperçoit que le
texte est modernité extraordinaire
il faut dire que la pièce aussi a été le
plus grand succès comique de Molière et
c'est vrai que quand là on l'ajout
depuis presque sans représentation les
gens rient les gens continuent à rire et
c'est ça c'est la force de la pièce de
Molière parce que au départ c'est un
drame
c'est des c'est complètement
aberrant ce vieil homme qui qui met
cette fille dans un couvent qu'il a fait
élever dans l'innocence la plus totale
et a peur d'être trompé c'est sa peur
viscéral et c'est ce qui va c'est ce qui
va lui arriver et ça c'est
extraordinaire et ça fait rire parce que
Molière est un auteur qui dénonce des
choses très très graves mais par le rire
et ça c'est la grande force je disais
que Molière et c'est un peu la grande
affaire de votre vie vous avez consacré
un livre vous lui avez consacré aussi
d'un spectacle sur sa vie et puis vous
l'avez beaucoup joué quand vous avez eu
le premier prix de comédie au
Conservatoire que vous êtes entré à la
Comédie Française vous avez beaucoup
joué Molière vous avez joué aux races
justement
non non non non ça ça décolle des femmes
j'avais jamais joué ni même un petit
rôle ni rien dans
les premières fois que que je me c'est
un rôle en plus qui est
assez extraordinaire c'est un des plus
beaux rôles du répertoire français c'est
un des plus longs aussi
comment dire apprécier un autre Bergerac
qui a mis le verre
Arnolphe à 850 vert
ah oui c'est presque autant oui oui
c'est ça quand on s'imagine Cyrano un
rôle évidemment et c'est vrai que c'est
oui il est très présent c'est aussi
c'est d'ailleurs aussi une pièce en
verre il faut le il faut le préciser
alors on va on va parler de ce spectacle
qui est un peu particulier ce spectacle
je lui dis en famille avec avec Gerson
de votre épouse avec votre fille qui
joue Agnès avec votre fils Louis alors
évidemment
la foi très très touchée et très heureux
de voir Louis sur scène parce que vous
l'aviez raconté dans dans un livre qui
s'appelait Louis Pasapa
c'est un enfant qui a été diagnostiqué
autiste et sévère quand il était quand
il était enfant et le voilà sur scène
aujourd'hui c'est quand même un parcours
incroyable et être humain exceptionnel
oui c'est ça qui est merveilleux c'est
ce qu'on et puis c'est son plaisir c'est
de jouer de d'être en scène cette
énergie elle on se demandait bon
on savait qu'il allait qu'il allait y
arriver on a beaucoup travaillé mais
comme avec les autres comédiens
d'ailleurs c'est mais on se disait
est-ce que ça va être régulier parce
qu'on a on joue
près de 100 présentations on arrive à 95
représentations et
ben il a toujours la même énergie la
même régularité le même professionnel
que d'autres camps et surtout cette joie
d'être en scène et ce plaisir de
partager et avec le public
c'est ça qui c'est ce qui est frappant
d'ailleurs c'est c'est en effet oui pour
lui ça doit être une joie immense
évidemment pour vous pour Gersende et
pour sa sœur Clarisse c'est aussi une
loi immense que vous partagez tous quoi
c'est un étonnement de chaque instant
aussi mais en même temps c'est ce qui
fait aussi que notre famille
a une complicité depuis depuis très très
très longtemps et qu'elle se recent en
scène et que les spectateurs sentent
cette joie d'être ensemble aussi et
cette admiration enfin qu'on a envers
lui parce qu'on est tout de même
oui oui on est à la fois fier heureux et
puis surtout très très heureux de le
voir de le voir dans cette joie de joie
immense de jouer surtout que voilà ce
que vous racontiez d'ailleurs dans dans
Louis pas à pas c'était cette vieille
des moments évidemment très difficiles
on a dit à Gerson c'était une mauvaise
des psy on dit ça qui était une mauvaise
mère que vous avez dit en perdre trop
âgée
alors il y a eu des bonbons très durs il
y a aussi des moments formidables parce
que vous avez rencontré aussi des des
gens formidables et puis et puis et puis
vous avez donné votre tout votre amour
enfin
à Louis et et probablement que ça ça
l'amène aujourd'hui sur scène tout ça
c'est ça je pense que c'est grâce au
traitement ABA l'analyse du comportement
appliquée donc qui est un traitement
sans médicament qui est un traitement de
stimulation et qui a permis que Louis
grâce aux intervenants qu'on a eu quand
il était
tout petit et donc à cette
oui je crois cette détermination qu'on
avait qui fasse des progrès et lui aussi
cette envie de progresser et qu'il a
encore et qui fait tous les jours ça
c'est formidable
et le fait de vous voir le fait de vous
avoir vu sur scène vous Gersende
ça l'a attiré vers ce métier
oui je pense qu'il a il a toujours aimé
ça et puis et puis il a trouvé il a
trouvé sa voix parce que il a on avait
dit qu'il serait jamais
sociable enfin et il a une sociabilité
extraordinaire parce qu'il a il a envie
de partager avec les gens après
d'ailleurs il dit vous m'avez trouvé
bien
oui je joue un bel Horace donc il est
le fait d'être heureux parce que nous
c'est ce qu'on voulait qu'il soit
heureux dans sa vie qu'il est qu'il soit
pas
il est très conscient de sa différence
mais mais il a des choses à faire
partager
ce qu'on voulait c'est qu'il soit
heureux et je pense qu'il est
entièrement et qu'il a trouvé là
un moyen de s'exprimer qui est assez
extraordinaire
et le fait d'être entouré de son père de
sa mère de sa sœur c'est c'est je pense
quelque chose aussi dans ce spectacle je
pense quelque chose d'important non
comédiens qui
avec qui il a des rapports assez
extraordinaires ça puis et puis il est
heureux de les retrouver là on n'a pas
joué
tu vas donc on va
on est en train de répéter et tout le
bonheur de retrouver les autres
et d'être d'être en famille
et d'autres familles absolument et et
vous vous avez joué votre rôle
évidemment de metteur en scène pour pour
cette école des femmes et avec avec oui
c'est un travail particulier ou comme
vous le disiez presque normal comme avec
un autre comédien
il a fallu non on a adapté monsieur nous
on a travaillé comme avec les autres
sauf qu'on lui disait bah tu viendras
quand ça sera tes scènes et tout parce
que parce qu'entre les trucs que lui il
est il était pas il s'est intéressé
après quand le spectacle s'est joué pour
d'ailleurs il sait tous les rôles c'est
ça qui est extraordinaire il sait tous
les rôles de tous les comédiens
d'ailleurs de temps en temps quand on
répète il nous fait des imitations on
est mort de rire
il paraît que les mais il paraît que les
les grands comédiens se font ça il faut
apprendre le rôle des autres pour être
très naturel non
oui moi je non moi j'apprends pas
j'écoute et puis voilà je réponds mais
vous avez déjà vos 850 verres à savoir
donc
c'est vrai
et l'accueil du public alors vous l'avez
dit vous vous tournez avec ce spectacle
depuis quelques mois maintenant presque
sans représentation et un
depuis un an autour depuis un an c'est
ça oui
et l'accueil du public est formidable
pour cette école des femmes
absolument absolument
à tous les comédiens avant de rentrer en
entrée en scène je dis n'oubliez pas
qu'on joue un chef-d'œuvre et ça c'est
très important parce que c'est vrai que
c'est un chef-d'oeuvre et c'est un peu
rassurant quoi je veux dire parce que et
on voit que ce que la pièce porte elle a
été écrite en 1662
Molière avait 40 ans donc quand il l'a
créé
et ce succès que enfin qu'il a eu parce
que
et les attaques qui ont suivi qui sont
sont suivis
parce qu'il a été très très attaqué
même plus que Tartuffe
parce qu'il dénonçait cette
ce féminisme enfin
qu'il avait de
c'est ça qui est c'est ça la force de la
pièce oui
sur les femmes telles qu'elles étaient
très pratiques à l'époque donc on
comprend on comprend qu'elle qui ait eu
des réactions très très négatives sur
cette pièce
et c'est vrai que vous disiez la
modernité de L'École des femmes et
absolument fantastique quand on se
rappelle voilà c'est c'est comme uber le
400e anniversaire de la naissance de
Molière écoutez merci infiniment Francis
Perrin donc le 25 novembre vous serez au
bureau et puis on suppose que la tournée
va continuer dans les dans les villes de
France parce que c'est un spectacle
absolument exceptionnel et voilà et
qu'on a envie de voir et pour vous et
pour les acteurs qui vous en retour et
pour Louis aussi parce que je pense que
c'est aussi un grand espoir pour un
certain nombre de parents
je pense je pense que c'est ça qui est
important parce que là on montre on
montre qu'il y a il y a quelque chose à
faire et rien rien n'est jamais perdu
grâce à vous grâce à vous grâce à
l'amour et à l'amour du théâtre aussi
merci beaucoup Francis merci
[Musique]